[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
bienvenue dans ça vous regarde au
sommaire ce soir l'heure de vérité pour
emmanuel macron alors que l'épidémie est
hors de contrôle
le président de la république doit faire
des annonces importantes demain à 20
heures leur confinement total du pays
n'est plus exclue c'est la piste
privilégiée même si d'autres options
sont sur la table comme enr confiné sans
tuer l'économie
c'est notre grand débat ce soir et dans
ce contexte comment lutter contre la
déprime généralisée la deuxième vague le
terrorisme la peur du lendemain
l'enchaînement des événements mortifère
plombent le moral des français alors
qu'observe-t-on précisément que nous
disent les indicateurs quel sursaut
possible décryptage
à suivre avec nos invités et puis notre
grand témoin ce soir lui reste optimiste
c'est un économiste professeur au
collège de france reconnue mondialement
il vient de publier un livre qui nous
explique que nous sommes à l'aube d'une
révolution technologique majeure est
riche en emplois philippe aghion est
avec nous ce soir voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti hashtag sévère
pour réagir tout de suite le grand débat
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir philippe aghion une choix
remercie infiniment d'être avec nous
vous êtes notre grand témoin ce soir
économiste professeur au collège de
france et à la london school of
economics de londres
vous avez longtemps enseigné aux états
unis à l'université de harvard et vous
publier ce livre le pouvoir de la
destruction créatrice coécrit avec
céline antonin
simon busnel chez odile jacob on va en
parler tout à l'heure dans le détail
mais l'actualité
ce soir ce sont d'abord les choix on est
à l'heure des choix pour emmanuel macron
l'accélération brutale de l'épidémie
l'obligent à prendre de nouvelles
mesures restrictives de liberté
restrictive aussi pour pour l'économie
bonsoir jean louis touraine
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
la république en marche du rhône
professeur de médecine vous revenez
notamment de votre circonscription de
saint-etienne là où les hôpitaux sont en
voie d'être saturé vous nous vous nous
raconterez bonsoir martin blachier merci
d'être là vous êtes médecin de santé
publique
epidémiologiste fondateur de public
santé publique l expertise othman
mastrou premier vice-président de la
région ile-de-france va nous rejoindre
dans un instant et puis bon soir
stéphane bonsoir myriam bonsoir à tous à
quelle sauce va t'on être re confiné
votre regard tout de suite si j'ai bien
compris pour démarrer ce débat si j'ai
bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris
myriam ça y est c'est officiel le
couvre-feu qui a été instaurée il ya
quinze jours pour stopper la propagation
du virus s'est avérée totalement
inefficace on peut lire puisque le
président avait lui-même fixé un
objectif en disant il faudrait passer
sous le seuil des 5000 nouveaux cas par
jour
aujourd'hui on en est en tout cinquante
mille nouveaux cas par jour et encore ce
ne sont que les cas officiels et n'est
vraisemblablement plus du double donc le
couvre-feu est inefficace
il va donc falloir prendre de nouvelles
mesures à bâle a hélas un parce que
c'était moins dur hélas on n'y coupera
pas myriam un lacis les services de
réanimation ont menacé de saturer donc
si on veut pas se retrouver avec des
couloirs d'hôpitaux dans lesquelles les
gens en meurent sans pouvoir être soigné
il faut impérativement
on nécessairement m un tour de vis
supplémentaire contre le virus alors au
départ on nous a dit il ya plusieurs
scénarii envisagés on a entendu ça donc
avant le week-end vendredi déjà
ben justement dans la région rhône-alpes
de ces des médecins ont publié une
tribune en disant il faut durcir du
couvre-feu il faudrait que il commence à
19h puis même qui s'étend du week-end
alors pas en lisant ça on se disait mais
alors qu'est ce qui va nous rester c'est
là c'est vraiment le métro boulot dodo
la solution hyper déprimante et puis en
réalité cette solution déprimante
c'est quand même la moins déprimante de
toutes les solutions déprimante parmi
lesquels il faut choisir pourquoi quels
sont les autres scénarii barras est
aussi un des problèmes c'est que vous
savez que depuis le début de la crise on
danse s'appuie sur les scientifiques
mais ils sont rarement d'accord entre
eux pour savoir quelle est la meilleure
solution c'est encore un peu le cas
aujourd'hui chacun y va un peu de de son
avis donc plus ou moins strictes donc
par exemple le professeur fontanes et
qui est membre du conseil scientifique
donc ce qui lui donne malgré tout une
certaine autorité lui disait ben oui il
faut reconfigurer certainement
maintenant c'est grave mais on pourrait
le faire de manière localisée de manière
ciblée en quelque sorte géographiquement
ça paraît logique quand on voit par
exemple le taux d'occupation des
services de régulation voit bien que
c'est pas du tout la même chose en grand
test ou en rhône-alpes donc pourquoi
apporte à peu appliqué la même mesure à
deux régions les situations sont très
différentes
alors quitte à cibler pour et ciblées en
fonction des populations il ya ce ce
clip qui passe en permanence où l'on dit
que 90% des décès sont en plus de 65 ans
donc pourquoi cibler les plus de 65 ans
et les seniors c'est ce que proposait le
sachet bon il se trouve que je vous
épargne les détails m dans la revue
politique moyens que ça posait un
problème de constitutionnalité confiner
les seniors donc s'il conseil
constitutionnel n'est pas d'accord qu
est ce que vous les confiner les plus
âgés qu'est ce qui reste
si on peut pas confier des vieux qu'est
ce qu'on fait on confie les jeunes
évidemment ça s'est fait une autre
solution aussi ça c'est la solution du
professeur flahault qui était sur bfm tv
qui disait que selon lui pour mettre
après coup d'arrêt l'épidémie il
faudrait ne que ni les collèges ni des
lycées ni les universités ne fassent
leur entrée à la fin des vacances de la
toussaint il disait même que en primaire
il serait bon que les enfants de 6 ans
en portent des masques
bon évidemment si on se place d'un point
de vue strictement médical
la solution la plus efficace pour
stopper le virus
on la connaît tous et comme d'habitude
c'est souvent le professeur comme qui
prône les solutions des plus les plus
divers les plus raides et bien une fois
de plus voilà ce qu'il disait ce matin
là je crois qu'on a plus le choix
c'est à dire que le virus est tellement
présent parmi nous que là je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a plus le choix il
faut rire qu'on finit un peu comme l'ont
fait les irlandais et les gallois pour
remettre les pendules à l'heure se
permettent de se réorganiser arrêtez la
saturation du système hospitalier
notamment des réanimations mais peut-on
confiné sans ruiner l'économie alors que
celles en question myriam jour merci de
me l'avoir posée mais plutôt qu'ils
répondent par moi même je vais les
scripteurs répondre le spécialiste de
l'économie qui n'est pas affilié pas
comme ici mais plutôt bruno le maire
vous connaissez les mises de l'économie
et quand on lui parle de confinement
général
voilà ce qu'ils disaient c'était ya dix
jours ce que nous devons éviter
impérativement jean jacques bourdin
c'est leur confinement général des
français parce que ça aurait un impact
social et psychologique sera donc et un
souci et un impact économique
insupportable pour l'économie française
insupportable vous avez entendu que
voilà ce que je voulais vous en assurez
vous avez entendu comme moi un effet
insu je suis entièrement d'accord que ce
sens je pense est une folie et il ne
faut pas laisser les épidémiologistes
décider seul je pense que les
économistes doivent être associés à la
décision parce qu'en plus c'est un
sacrifice des jeunes à l'égard des gens
à gerland que je pense qu'il faut moi je
suis maintenant dans la classe des gens
plus âgés je pense que mais je pense
qu'on peut pas sacrifier des générations
de jeunes complètement pourri donc un
problème générationnel qu'il faut
prendre en compte également et donc être
fermé à l'idée de confinement sélectif y
compris par ajout par ou en fonction des
pathologies
je pense que c'est une attitude
dogmatique et je pense que retourner au
confinement total serait une grave
erreur
alors je pense comprendre l'économie à
prendre l'économie en compte parce que
l'économie elle a des répercussions sur
la santé également alors ils sont partis
en compte par les épidémiologistes et ça
il faut le dire alors on le débat et le
décor est planté merci beaucoup stéphane
je vais revenir vers vous philippe
aghion georges l'instant mais vous avez
vous avez bien fait de répondre la
question vous était directement adressés
martin blachier on va faire une petite
photographie rapide de ce qui est en
train de se passer hors de contrôle
l'épidémie aujourd'hui totalement dans
le pays oui absolument
totalement de contrôle il ya un
phénomène nouveau qui est arrivé avec
les mauvais jours ça peut paraître
grotesque mais c'est vrai il a parlé
mais quasiment tous d'accord à dire
qu'il ya que les chutes de températures
qui peuvent expliquer cet emballement
qui a la particularité d'être partout
c'est dans tous les départements
français ou prenez chacun des
départements vous aider cinétique donc
changer de radio
c'est ce qui explique l'accélération
brutale des cas de contamination qui a
surpris tout le monde
c'est même plus que ça en fait on peut
considérer qu' il ya une épidémie de
l'été et à une épidémie de l'automne est
le facteur climatique écrase tous les
autres c'est à dire que tout ce qu'on a
fait jusqu'à présent c'est rien du tout
par rapport aux facteurs climatiques
afin que l'effet du couvre-feu
il a tout écrasé ce qui veut dire
d'ailleurs que tous les mauvais procès
qui sont faits aux décisions qui
n'auraient pas été prises aujourd'hui ça
devient grotesque puisque le facteur
climatique fait que de toute façon on ne
réussit à être président que le froid
ils n'éduquent teneurs non ça veut dire
qu'on est plus souvent à l'intérieur
qu'à l'extérieur donc il ya plus de
contamination c'est la principale
différence avec la première vague weeps
pas la différence avec la première vague
c'est qu'il est partout en fait on sait
contaminé on s'est confiné extrêmement
tôt en fait contrairement à ce qu'on a
pu en être extrêmement réactif quand
c'est arrivé en france et donc du coup
on s'est confiné tellement tôt que le
virus n'avait même pas eu le temps
diffusé dans l'intégralité du territoire
ça avait été cantonné à l'île de france
et au grand test aujourd'hui évidemment
pendant l'été à bas bruit il a pu
transiter dans toutes les différentes
zones de france qui fait que quand vous
avez comme ramener le gaz sur une
gazinière sa pure flambé dans tous les
territoires et d'ailleurs c'est un
phénomène qui touche toute l'europe
c'est un phénomène qui touche les états
unis essaient même contrairement à ce
qu'on dit un phénomène qui touche l'asie
puis sur son compte encore il ya des
foyers qui sont en train de se rallumer
en asie en particulier sur nous mêmes
latitudes
moi c'est les informations que c'est
parce que taiwan va bien alors j'ai des
amis au vietnam qui me disent que le
gouvernement vietnamien je viens de dire
qu'il devait plus aller en corée au
japon ou en chine
c'est vraiment des raisons donc c'est un
phénomène qui est globale qui touche
tout le monde et en fait c'est cette
vague de froid a remis tout le monde sur
un pied d'égalité ce qui a fait dire que
tous les petits débats qu'on a eu entre
nous pendant cet été
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas qu'on a des
confiné trop vite c'est pas qu'on a raté
quelque chose au moment d'aider confier
quelque chose qui nous attendait qui
était inéluctable qu'un facteur
saisonnier qui est bien le glas de tout
ce qu'on avait pu images
pendant l'été je répète le plein de méta
analyse d'éditoriaux de tous les plus
grands scientifiques qu'on dit on
enterre l'hypothèse de la saisonnalité
il ya rien qui pouvait nous préparer un
facteur saisonnier aussi fort
aujourd'hui on est devant le fait
accompli et un objet de prendre des
décisions qui sont pratiques qui sont
plus des décisions épidémiologique
d'ailleurs parce que savoir s'il faut
qu'on finisse il faut pas confiné c'est
des décisions de société c'est des
décisions d'économistes voilà c'est plus
aux médecins de parler de face on n'a
rien à dire la seule chose c'est le
confinement donc il faut pas que ce soit
que les médecins qui les sites ça on
peut pas refaire comme avant ça c'est
pas possible on peut pas laisser la
discrétion aux médecins seulement ça
doit être des médecins des économistes
des sociologues
je pense que oui je pense qu'il y avait
c'était trop monsieur comment il
s'appelle la jeu ça peut pas voilà je
pense à dell prévoit la ville est très
bien très bien mais ça peut pas être
juste lui qui décide
ça c'est pas possible bonsoir othman
natrue merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
premier vice-président de la région
ile-de-france du parti de mme pécresse
libre vous êtes depuis le début de la
crise en lien avec le préfet
d'ile-de-france pour mettre en place
toutes ses mesures restrictives à
s'interroger sur le scénario du moindre
mal du moindre mal pour notre économie
jean louis touraine on sait que voilà il
ya une heure de vérité il ya un choix à
faire
confinement total avec les écoles qui
resteraient ouvertes à l'image de
l'irlande ou du pays de galles pour vous
est ce que c'est la solution
je pense que le maître des horloges
c'est le virus se sont pas les décideurs
ni médicaux ni politique ni elle ni
économique c'est le virus qui crée la
dynamique et cette dynamique on le voit
vient de s'accélérer d'une façon
imprévue en tout cas plus un plus ample
que ce qui était anticipé
et donc je crois qu'il faut réagir il
faut réagir en proportion des
compliments tonale retourner notre
devoir et suis une réactivité
si la france en est à peu près sorti
décemment lors de la première vague
c'est parce que l'érection était
opportune par rapport à des pays qui ont
voulu nier la dynamique du virus
lui-même
j'ai pas besoin de citer ces pays vous
connaissez bien entendu les etats-unis
le brésil la grande-bretagne
on a vu les conséquences donc on ne peut
pas nier un phénomène qui s'imposent à
nous
donc il faut une certaine forme de
confinement après il faut que ce
confinement sur le moins douloureux
possible et donc le moins douloureux
possible c'est quoi c'est la corse et le
confinement qui soit assez globale qui
soit amplifiée auprès des populations
les plus vulnérables c'est-à-dire qu'on
les responsabilisant leur demandant d'
elle-même volontairement
on ne peut pas les autres disent et se
soustraire aux risques de même que quand
viendront le moment des fêtes
si on est toujours en situation
difficile il faudra expliquer
inlassablement qu'il n'est pas ça même
pour noël que des personnes âgées et
prennent dans leurs bras leurs petits
enfants
il faudra attendre peut-être le mois de
mai ce que font les suédois vous savez
moi j'ai ri cho côte près proche de la
suède
les personnes âgées en suède elles
connaissent c'est exactement ça des
relais
les jeunes générations font en sorte
qu'ils voient pas leurs enfants que et
une responsabilité il ya un esprit de
responsabilité je dis pas déçu donc fait
le sait pas le premier choix qui a été
qui a été créée au départ c'était de de
ne pas entraver la jeune fille mais je
ne dis pas que il faut suivre la méthode
suédois se montrent pas c'était très
intéressant qui sont revenus de 8 ils
ont 10 ans escompté l'immunité
collective comment douala ça ça n'a pas
fonctionné
mais ils on voit là mais il ya quand
même cette attitude des joueurs plus
âgés qui disent nous on fait très
attention il ya des relents de gestes
alors vous êtes ils devront faire plus
un confinement raisonnable c'est bien
sûr
vraisemblablement la région d'interdire
par exemple le fonctionnement des
universités ou de les leur faire part
des met les moyens est déjà quasiment je
viens de fonctionnement des écoles
laisser les administrations publiques
les services publics laisser toute la
partie possible de l'économie en
fonctionnement et donc si on fait cela
pendant l'espace d'un mois
eh bien on peut avoir en recul mais il
faudra bien bien négocié le
déconfinement pour pas avoir
immédiatement un retour dans cette case
sous prétexte de fêtes de noël retrouver
à nouveau né vie parce que l'enjeu c'est
de tenir plusieurs mois dans plusieurs
mois nous aurons vraisemblablement un
vaccin mais c'est dans plusieurs mois
il faut tenir ce temps là - traitement
et il faut essayer de ne plus faire trop
lourde pour vous il ya des soient tirées
du déconfinement il a été mal géré c'est
pas une question mal géré c'est qu'il
est très difficile de s'adresser la
totalité des populations ce n'est ni la
télévision et les journaux qui s'adresse
aux jeunes populations qui s'adresse aux
populations les plus vulnérables qui a
transporté le plus le virus dans ces
derniers temps les gens précaires et les
jeunes c'est eux qui ont le + france
mais là on va en parler des jeunes parce
que la question des écoles est sur la
table aux mânes nasro vous vous êtes en
lien avec avec les autorités depuis le
début où on dit que ces mesures elles
doivent être concertées dans un dialogue
pour les rendre acceptables
vous savez un petit peu à quelle sauce
on va être mangé ou pas du tout est-ce
que vous avez des informations ce soir
malheureusement la concertation ne va
pas plusieurs élus locaux le disent haut
niveau on aimerait qu'elle soit c'est à
dire que nous serons probablement demain
la décision définitive ce qu'on sait
d'ores et déjà c'est que la situation
est telle que l'on s'attend
effectivement à des mesures relativement
drastique parmi toutes les hypothèses
qui ont été évoqués ici et c'est vrai
que les chiffres peut-être d'un
confinement total sauf secteurs
stratégiques vous savez ce qu'on met
derrière ce mot de secteurs stratégiques
au delà des commerces alimentaires de
première nécessité
non mais je crois que la citation
télétravail peut être renforcé avec tout
un tas un champ de l'économie qui
pourrait fonctionner malgré tout si les
choses sont organisées je crois que la
question des écoles pour permettre aussi
aux gens de travailler pas simplement
d'être dans la garde de leurs enfants
elle est centrale pour vous cette
question il est évidemment centrale et
la réalité c'est qu'on aurait tous aimé
ne pas se retrouver dans cette situation
c'est là où j'entends la saisonnalité
mais la réalité c'est que on voit qu'il
ya des choses aussi qui n'ont pas
marcher danser dans la gestion de cette
crise et si on ne le voit pas
aujourd'hui on prend le risque d'être
dans un scénario on va dire de d'arrêt
et de reprise progressive de l'épidémie
traverse un moment aussi très politique
parce que les français vont se dire
qu'est ce qui n'a pas marché on se
retrouve au point au point de départ
vous parlez vous parlez de la
saisonnalité martin blachier sur les
écoles on voudrait savoir est ce qu'on
sait à ce stade des études si les
enfants sont contaminateur s'il n'est
pas dangereux de les laisser à l'école
enfin sujets plus controversés kso lula
énormément d'études qui commencent à
sortir
il ya des études qui disent non les
enfants à transmettre très peu et on
peut pas dire que les écoles soient un
foyer de contamination une propagation
du virus et puis ya des écoles qui
disent les enfants sont de potentiels
super spray d'heure aux etats unis ils
ont été extrêmement prudents sur les
écoles en soit il ya tout un courant
d'études qui vous montrent que les
écoles ne peuvent pas être avoir un rôle
clé dans la propagation de l'épidémie on
ne sait pas et une étude asiatiques qui
vient de montrer que les enfants
pouvaient être super prêteurs on n'en
sait rien mais là encore une fois je
crois que c'est plus la question du
choix de société qu'il faut se poser
plus tôt on y vient mais juste que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il ya une chose
qu'il faut pas qu'on rate c'est la
création d'une bulle protectrice autour
de la population vulnérable parce que
c'est ça qui va déterminer mais c'est
quoi une bulle protectrice et ben le
problème c'est qu'il faut que ce soit
fois il faut un glissé pour leur faire
leurs courses en perf à l'usagé
cet écran qui puisse les sortir de
l'isolément malgré le fait qu'ils aient
pas de contacts à risque il faut des
gens qui leur apporte à manger il faut
mettre en place peut-être des solutions
digitales pour éviter qu'elles se
sentent trop seul
il faut faire tout ce qu'on peut pour
éviter que cette population souffre trop
parce que le président macron il peut
dire ce qu'il veut demain mais de toute
façon
jusqu'en mars on va devoir gérer cette
question à cette question il faut la
gérer avec les gens il faut les jouer
avec les associations vous la gérez que
les mecs les élus aussi personnelle et
mairie les régions on ne pourra je vais
très clair on ne pourra jamais des
confiné cette population là tant qu'on
n'aura pas de vaccin donc cette
populaire autant se sont préoccupés tout
de suite de cette question à la
direction entend l'étendre accusé de
dire on fait un confinement cette
population là pour protéger la jeunesse
un petit peu encore sacrifier la
jeunesse pendant quelques semaines et
dans quelques semaines qu'est ce qu'on
va faire lire la jeunesse va bien
falloir qu'elle retournait les vaccins
pour préciser des choses on entend
parler d'un vaccin en chine c'est pas
pour aujourd'hui un vaccin testable ce
qu'on dit c'est qu'on aura des
informations pour savoir si ça marche si
ça marche pas au début de l'année et
qu'on les aura probablement à
disposition plutôt premier semestre 2021
qui sont plus pessimistes et qui disent
plutôt 2022 si les gens acceptent de se
faire vacciner enfin il ya tout un tas
de ici ici je pense que la solution du
vaccin c'est un espoir mais aujourd'hui
ça va pas être une variable de de
l'équation
à mon avis c'est peu le problème c'est
cet hiver il ya peu de chances qu'on est
un vaccin avant la fin de cet hiver
alors j'aime tourner vers d'économistes
on entendait bruno le maire dirk un
confinement total et explose parce que
l'économie ne le supporterais pas si on
remet à l'arrêt l'économie je vais bien
je dis bien fait il faut être
extrêmement prudent
personne ne sait ce que va annoncer le
président la république mais si
l'économie s'arrêtait la même manière
qu'elle s'est arrêtée en février mars en
fin mars avril
est ce qu est ce qu on pourrait s'en
remettre je remets toujours jédir on
peut toujours se remettre mais il c'est
vrai que ça que ça créerait vraiment
beaucoup de faillites par exemple y
aurait beaucoup d'entreprises qui aurait
pu continuer et qui vont être obligés de
matha clé sous la porte
alors évidemment savez comment ça marche
l'économie ya d'abord les secteurs qui
sont directement touchés les restaurants
les hôtels l'aéronautique les arènes
manière mais ces secteurs là sont
directement touchés touré puis ensuite
le problème c'est que s'ils sont pas
soutenues d'envoyer demande
on va
l'état va les soutenir mais ça fait
baisser la demande et ça ça touche après
indirectement les autres secteurs
voiliers qui sont pas directement
touchés mais qui sont touchés parce que
la demande pour leurs produits baissent
donc c'est tout ça et donc si vous
voulez donc l effet direct sur les
secteurs touchés directement il ya
l'effet induit donc il ya le choc des
deux d'emplois directement sur secteur
l'effet induit de demandes sur les
autres et si vous voulez si ça dure trop
longtemps ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de faillites il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui disparaît l'état a les
moyens de soutenir ces secteurs avec le
chômage partiel avec les vraies
garanties par l'état est ce que
aujourd'hui les taux d'intérêt étant
tellement voyons c'est la même chose on
peut continuer finalement cette
politique là de soutien oui on peut
absolument non on peut continuer mais
enfin c'est sûr que c'était malade
si vous les combats en même temps oui
mais en même temps j'ai dit myriam ci
est ce qui se passe c'est que on veut on
veut soutenir la demande mais d'un autre
côté vous savez très bien qu'il ya un
gros problème d'offre
qu est ce qu a révélé le coc vide c'est
que nous avions excessivement d
industrialiser on s'est rendu compte
qu'on manquait de respirateurs qu'on
manquait de principe actif et il fallait
et après on a fait la radiographie de
l'économie française on a vu qu'à part
le nucléaire et l'aéronautique
on avait la france avait perdu dans
beaucoup de domaines donc le plan de
relance c'est à la fois soutien à la
demande ce que ça a été tout au début
mais également un soutien à l'offre pour
réindustrialiser et on veut pas qu à
nouveau tout part dans là uniquement du
côté de la demande est rien pour
réindustraliser parce qu'il ya vraiment
une urgence
donc il est bien calé à la maîtrise de
nos chaînes de valeur l'innovation
l'innovation il faut financer
là on parle de vaccins mais savez ça
tombe pas du ciel le vaccin ou les
traitements parce qu'il se peut très
bien que ce soit comme pour le sida que
finalement son traitement mais autant
qu'un vaccin on n'en sait rien
finalement et mais ça il faut
l'innovation alors la pl dessus les
américains sont meilleurs que nous on
est très mauvais ils sont très mauvais
sur le plan social mais sur l'innovation
ils sont meilleurs que nous et nous on
doit investir dans des familles a dit
dans un rapport récent qu'au fond il
fallait mieux avoir des mesures strictes
radical est clair si derrière la crise
sanitaire était maîtrisée autrement dit
mieux vaut s'arrêter de façon ponctuelle
net et derrière il ya un rebond
on touche le fond on remonte très vite
en exponentiel
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse c'est une trêve de mesures
gravier graduée qui sont plus anxiogène
sur la confiance
non mais je pense qu'effectivement il je
crois qu'il ya un juste milieu moi je
crois je trouve qu enfin là je trouve
que ce que vous avez évoquées comme
mesures possibles ou ce que vous avez
évoqué je trouve ça fait sens
c'est-à-dire un conte un confinement
ciblées en gros ce qu'il faut et est
beaucoup d'études économiques montrent
également qu'il faut un confinement
ciblées et puis après des mesures et les
c'est aussi la société civile parce que
voyez ce qu'il ya c'est que moi je crois
beaucoup dans le triangle entre le
marché les entreprises qui innovent
parce que finalement le vaccin et les
traitements ça va venir des entreprises
et les entreprises qui vont créer là qui
vont réindustrialiser cl
mais l'état est là pour assurer pour
amortir le choc pour nous assurer pour
nous aider mais il ya la société civile
qui joue alors le portugal par exemple a
eu des résultats formidables parce que
la société civile à jouer si vous avez
trop on est trop coercitif vous tuer la
la la société civile vous l'empêchez de
l elle aussi de prendre le relais il
faut un bon équilibre entre l'état et la
société civile outre magna soit juste le
confinement par classe d'âge il a aussi
tout à fait ses limites parce qu'au bout
d'un moment on pousse pas jusque là je
sais par pathologie exhale marrant c'est
que demander aussi à des activités il
faut aussi que les mesures qui soient
proposées soit soutenable aussi là pour
les pour les personnels déçu et penser
que l'on va demander jusqu'à l'été 2021
à des gens de se calfeutrer parce
qu'elles sont trop âgés
ça me paraît aussi très difficile en
sachant qu'elles peuvent malgré tout
être gagné par le virus parce qu'ils ont
quand même une famille où cohabitent pas
toujours seul mémé sur le sujet
économique là où ça a été dit
pareillement kawa c'est que le plan de
relance il est évidemment partie
obsolètes aujourd'hui je veux dire là
maintenant qu'il est très clair qu'on va
devoir continuer à vivre avec ce virus
mais de manière beaucoup plus forte que
ce qu'on pouvait penser encore quelques
semaines il va falloir aménager les
choses beaucoup plus durablement
il ya peut-être des taux de tva a
repensé comme on l'a fait en allemagne
sont intacts et la tva rage et bien sûr
les activités qui peuvent perdurer
malgré un confinement ou des
restrictions supplémentaires par exemple
la restauration à emporter la livraison
tout un tas de baisser la tva pour
relancer la consommation de
l'indispensable jean louis touraine oui
oui oui oui c'est une est favorable
c'est une belle miles à la fête peut pas
dire que c'est réalisable demain mais
c'est étudié comme une des possibilités
oui moi je pense que il ya d'autres ya
d'autres choses aussi vous pouvez vous
pouvez aussi par exemple ça nous
introduire un impôt négatif par exemple
pour contre la pauvreté par exemple vous
pouvez dire au dessous d'un certain
niveau vous recevez un chèque
parce que finalement ce qu'on veut c'est
parce qu'il faut faire attention à la
baisse de tva s'applique à tout le monde
vous savez très bien que je suis d'un
certain niveau les gens ont épargné le
problème n'était pas parce que beaucoup
de gens accumulent et de l'épargné qui
n'ont pas pu dépenser justement dont par
contre les plus vulnérables il faut vous
savez donc il faut maintenir leur
consommation donc il faut des mesures
qui aident les plus vulnérables à
pouvoir continuer pour survivre et bien
donc là c'est des mesures qui doivent
être ciblés voir que sur les torrent le
plus touché ce sont les plus vulnérables
voilà exactement ce qu'on doit être
ciblée des re il faut cibler nos nous
voilà donc là aussi faut cibler et je
pense que ça nous exhorte à une agilité
voilà il ne faut rien prendre rien
exclure a priori mais rien prendre pour
chacun dans c'est pas parce qu'on a vécu
pendant 20 30 ans avec tel ou tel doxa
il nous faut être capable de remettre en
route
c'est peut-être même ça d'ailleurs
puisque tout à l'heure vous parliez
d'espoir c'est peut-être même cette
volonté de dire qu allons nous sortir de
positif de cette terrible épreuve
ce n'est pas le problème c'est qu'on
n'en est pas sorti encore mais bien sûr
mais c'est à ce moment qu'il faut le
faire vous savez le conseil gardez la
lumière de cette instance ici rue unique
de la france était occupée
ils ont élaboré la sécurité sociale et
beaucoup d'autres réformes
alors est-ce que la france n'était pas
libéré donc merci à eux bravo à eux
mais faisons la même chose avant d'avoir
terminé voilà cette épidémie locaux
vides nous devons élaborer un monde
secondaire ou j'adhère tout à fait ce
qui vient d'être dit il nous faut que la
france soit à nouveau impérial ariel
c'est c'est pas acceptable que vous
dispensez de même de résister mais
permettre il s'est donné encore dans les
services
et c'est l'optimisme qu'on bas-rhin et
et industriel c'est un pays industriel
mais sur le terrain c'est pour j'entends
bien j'entends dire très important parce
que pour l'instant mais ça ça prend du
temps et là y'a les mesures d'urgence et
on est dans la crise sanitaire
je voudrais vous interroger sur au fond
l'acceptabilité de ces mesures
en italie par exemple on voit que les
couvre-feux bien plutôt que chez nous où
commence à être contesté il ya des il ya
des manifestations
les élus que vous êtes au niveau
national au niveau local sont sondés
sont des traits d'union très important
avec les citoyens vous êtes associés
vous allez jouer le jeu comment comment
vous allez faire concrètement pour
les mesures qui seront prises et nous
région ile de france avec la présidente
de région l'a choisi d'accompagner et
quel que soit ce qui sera annoncé demain
évidemment dans la mesure de ce qui peut
être acceptable ce qui peut être
envisagée
ce qui est sur la table aujourd'hui nous
accompagnerons naturellement il y aura
un temps encore une fois pour les
responsabilités et pour les débats parce
que il ya des choses à tirer aussi de
ses enseignements si on veut pas revivre
ensuite une troisième salve leur fric
sur une quatrième une cinquième a bien
falloir voir ce qui a marché ou pas ce
que le suivi des contacts marche bien
aujourd'hui dans les délais qui sont
redescendus devais avoir 12 8
respirateur on al aqsa me l'a encore une
question quand même qui sont
déterminants légitime mais l'urgence du
moment elle n'est pas celle là elle est
d'accompagner les mesures restrictives
qui sera annoncée demain et en
particulier sur le plan économique parce
que il ya la question de la précarité
mais il ya la question de l'emploi est
la question des entreprises on a perdu
en ile-de-france 122 mille emplois
salariés en allant sur les suite aux
derniers confinement donc ça va devenir
bientôt insoutenable et donc malgré tout
les aides que nous mettons en oeuvre
l'état la région tout le monde joue sa
part là-dedans on continue à voir une
casse qui est terrible seule voie est
donc là dessus je suis curieux de savoir
ce que le gouvernement va comme envahir
un compagnie demain ce n'est attendait
les mesures de soutien ou cette
restriction supplémentaire pour l'emploi
et pour les entreprises
martin l'acier questions sur ces pays
qui ont confiné
israël a confié exemple même population
en termes de en termes de nombre et de
géographie ça marche ou pas oui ça
marche le confinement ça marche ça ça
casse la vague épidémique aussi bien les
contaminations qui ont fait un
recrutement général que les
hospitalisations qui suivent donc c'est
sûr que ça marche mais après c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait après tout à
l'heure vous disiez il ya une limite l
art confiner les populations les plus
vulnérables
d'accord vous à les confiner du coup
tout le monde pour veut pas comme tout
le monde soit d'accord mais tout ce que
confie donc comme ça y'a pas de
discrimination comme on dit je vois pas
où est la discrimination vaccine les
personnes de plus de 65 ans contre la
grippe on dit pas qu'on les a supervisés
par les squatters l'unité collective
donc vous ne faites pas ça je vous allez
comprendre vous ne faites pas ça et donc
ça veut dire que dans 4 semaines vous
des conflits qu'est ce que vous faites
de la population une herbe et je vous
propose est ce que vous faites et sur
votre objectif est que tout le monde et
virus sauf les personnes vulnérables
non je vous ne savez pas aujourd'hui si
l'immunité est acquise définitivement
fin il me sens soulagé quand je termine
habilité au point de perdre une
démonstration serre que dans quatre
semaines pour des confiné tout le monde
si vous voulez vraiment rude et confiné
l'épidémie va repartir a réveillé
quelque chose qui existe dans la société
c'est la relation entre les générations
et je crois que moi ce que j'ai vécu
c'est que la génération des jeux entre
60 et 80 ans n'est pas prête à faire le
moindre effort pour la génération des
plus jeunes et je vous avoue que je le
vis mal et c'est quelque chose que je
retiendrai parce que la génération des
baby boomers
tout le monde est allé et personne ne
s'est dit qu'est ce que psg quand je
vois qu antoine flahault ose dire que ce
qu'il faut c'est fermer les écoles
fermées les collèges fermés les lycées
enfin enfermer la jeunesse pour protéger
les gens entre 60 à 80 ans je vous dis
un vrai problème à ces demandes étaient
assez vraiment délire ça va falloir
travailler ses délires avisé délire on
sacrifie cette génération doit pas
sacrifier complément la jeune génération
mais ça veut pas dire que c'est un jeu à
somme nulle c'est pas un jeu à somme
nulle
mais électoraliste mais bien sûr
pourquoi on refuse cette solution qui
est la meilleure solution économique et
les meilleures solutions politiques et
pourquoi vous vous êtes pas pour le
câble pour des raisons électorales
désolé de le dire et chez moi
j'appartiens génération qui est en train
de tout perdre on s'est eu tort et c'est
notre génération mais mes parents de
dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas ma
génération qui meurt et je suis désolé
de vous dire que quand on a 90 % des
décès qui concerne les plus de 65 ans on
pense d'abord à l'ajustement groupe de
protéger et quand on parle solidarité
intergénérationnelle on ne dresse pas
générations nées
c'est vrai on va pas on va pas vous
mettre pas confiance du tout à cause de
ça c'est fini d'être herbst est fini des
pierres elle est à matignon dans la cour
de l'hôtel matignon
bonsoir stéphanie vous avez suivi pour
nous les consultations de chef de parti
auprès de auprès de jean castex ce soit
qu'est-ce qui en est sorti est ce qu on
en a appris sur les différents scénarios
sur la table celui qui tiendrait la
corde est ce que les élus sont déçus ce
soir
eh bien écoutez jean castex et olivier
ferrand ont dressé un tableau très
sombre de la situation face aux élus les
chefs de partis de groupes politiques de
partis politiques leur ministre a
expliqué que le couvre-feu risquait de
ne pas suffire olivier ferrand expliqué
que c'était sûr dans d'ici quinze jours
les hôpitaux serait sa future est au
même niveau que la première vague mais
finalement l'issue de cette réunion les
groupes politiques et les partis à sont
déçus ça fait trois fois qu'on nous
consulte ça fait trois fois que ça sert
à rien disait tout à l'heure fabien
roussel 13h général du parti communiste
à droite comme à gauche à la sortie ils
sont donc déçu car le gouvernement n'a
pas donné ses scénarii ils ont donc eu
l'impression de qu'on leur demandait
leur avis sur rien écouté c'est au
premier ministre c'est à l'exécutif de
nous dire voilà les hypothèses voilà la
situation en fonction de ça voilà les
hypothèses que nous avons et quel est
votre avis c'est ce que nous attendions
tous et puis chacun peut prendre ses
responsabilités mais ça n'est pas à nous
de faire des propositions aujourd'hui
concrètement n'ont aucune mesure il nous
est dit lui même qui ne connaissaient
pas les mesures qu'annoncera le
président de la république ce qui nous a
aussi surpris c'est que le premier
ministre lui même nous a dit clairement
qu'il ne connaissait pas les hypothèses
donc on nous demande notre avis sur des
hypothèses qui ne seraient même pas
connus par le premier ministre sur ce
que serait l'impact par exemple un
confinement
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une forme de
flou assez généralisé qui fait que cette
réunion est apparu quand même comme
assez surprenante par rapport à ça nous
venons de vivre un voyage en absurdie où
l'on nous réunit pour nous demander
notre avis sur des mesures que l'on ne
connaît pas des hypothèses que l'on ne
connaît pas tout en nous indiquant que
le parlement sera amené à les voter
après que le président de la république
les aient décidées et annoncées bon ça
vous étonnera pas moi ça ne m'étonne pas
depuis le début on assiste à une gestion
complètement erratiques de la crise
sanitaire on aurait pu penser que en
tirerait les leçons de la première vague
la réalité c'est que on se retrouve dans
une situation pire
à l'aube de cette deuxième vague que la
situation qui était celle de notre pays
lors de la première vague comme marine
le pen da bien bas de le président du
groupe l'est républicain l'assemblée
nationale a dit qu'il était clairement
opposé un recond finement alors jean
castex le monsieur déconfinement de la
première vague sera-t-il bientôt le
monsieur confinement et bien réponse
demain soir c'est emmanuel macron qui
fera les annonces pour cette crise
sanitaire
merci beaucoup stéphanie des pierres
jean louis touraine qu'est ce que vous
répondez à marine le pen voyage en
absurdie euros
on nous consulte sur rien non non
parlement n'est pas respectée à preuve
c'est qu'ils sont tous présents à
matignon et sans savoir
et quid de la clastre qu'ils sont
écoutés alors maintenant il est clair
que on s'achemine vers vraisemblablement
un confinement un peu moins sévère que
lors du printemps dernier cependant il
est clair aussi que l'adhésion des
groupes politiques comme de la
population est moins facile pour la
deuxième vague
c'est naturel c'est oublier tout à fait
la même donc il faut à fait à voter un
j'ai dit je le rappelle est il faut
travailler pour essayer d'avoir le
meilleur consensus aussi au niveau local
dans notre région l'agglomération
lyonnaise tous partis confondus les gens
sont solidaires pour l'application des
mesures
et je pense que beaucoup de régions
françaises appliqueront de la même façon
solidairement ces mesures il reste bien
entendu à maintenir dans la population
en état psychologique qui ne soit pas
dépressif il faut nourrir l'espoir
l'espoir pour après mais aussi l'espoir
pour pouvoir traverser cette fin d'année
dans des conditions qui ne soient pas
excessivement douloureux peut-être
sauver noël il donc on peut imaginer on
en acide et quelques uns des exemples
pour aider ici les personnes âgées pour
la faire en sorte que les jeunes
puissent quand même avoir des activités
etc etc en
oui sans cet espoir que l'on va pouvoir
développer des actions qui demain nous
reconstruirons une france encore de la
confiance à la société civile pas juste
la cohérence merci à tous merci à tous
on sera évidemment très attentive très
attentifs demain aux annonces
présidentielles merci d'être venus
débattre sur lcp philippe aghion vous
restez avec nous on va parler à présent
d'un pouvoir un peu mystérieux le
pouvoir de la destruction créatrice
c'est le titre de votre à dire qu'on n'y
a le pouvoir de la destruction créatrice
chez odile jacob s'est autant d'ailleurs
je le dis un ouvrage de chercheurs en
économie il ya des modèles mathématiques
il ya des graphiques pour m'adonner
vient pas du côté joly mais c'est aussi
un guide pour penser l'avenir du
capitalisme alors pour commencer je vais
vous montrer une image une photographie
vous d'aller la découvrir à l'antenne je
le dis en attendant qu'elles
apparaissent là voilà on va la voir dans
les halles moi je la vois dans les
écrans de contrôle mais est-ce qu'on
peut la voir voilà c'est qui et cathy
lui comme intuitions géniales à écouter
donc donc c'est joseph schumpeter
d'accord donc économistes autrichiens
allard économiste autrichien qui a fini
comme professeur à harvard d'ailleurs on
a été mon lointain prédécesseur et il a
eu cette intuition de la destruction
créatrice il à dire voilà là
l'innovation la destruction créatrice et
ce processus par lequel de nouvelles
innovations viennent constamment
remplacer des technologies existantes et
les rendent obsolètes voilà est ce qu'il
a compris c'est qu'il y avait une
contradiction au coeur du processus
d'innovation et de croissance c'est à
dire que il faut des rentes à
l'innovation
mais ceux qui ont récompensé les
innovations prescrits étaient
intellectuelle âgée propriétaire
exactement monsieur skype est devenu
riche parce qu'ils inventent escaré
poule steve jobs est devenu riche parce
qu'il inventait apple mais le danger
c'est que ces rentes peuvent être
ensuite utilisées par ceux qui ont
innové hier pour empêcher de nouvelles
personnes d'innover deuil le danger que
ces gens là deviennent hégémonique et
qui bloque tout c'est un peu ce que font
les gars femmes d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
by donc schumpeter est un pessimiste en
fait profondément 7 qui disait voilà il
va y avoir d'innovation mais en fait ce
qu'ils ont innové la première vague
d'innovateur ils vont tout bloquer il y
aura pas de deuxième vague d'innovation
donc le capitalisme n'a pas d'avenir
parce que en fait ils auront les moyens
de bloquer toute innovation et nous
conte explique ici c'est que non vous
revisitez revisite sinon il ya un espoir
c'est pas nous en parler pour mieux
comprendre
au fond cette révolution technologique
qui nous attend et dans laquelle on est
finalement déjà et qui s'est accélérée
avec la crise sanitaire
on va regarder un sujet de clément
perreault comment ce progrès
technologique avec l'intelligence
artificielle en tête bien sûr bouleverse
d'ores et déjà notre quotidien regarder
on en parle juste après l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est la promesse d'un monde nouveau
plus connectés plus sécurisé et plus
automatisés mais à quoi tout cela
ressemblera petit tour d'horizon dans
trois secteurs clés de notre quotidien
la mobilité terrain de jeu privilégié de
l'intelligence artificielle les
véhicules deviennent autonomes avec deux
promesses fluidifier le trafic et faire
baisser les accidents
le défi sera bien sûr d'adapter le
réseau routier les normes de sécurité
mais les voitures sans pilote sont déjà
une réalité
selon le cabinet d'études américain
gartner sept cent quarante cinq mille
véhicules autonomes circuleront en 2023
un monde sans caissier c'est déjà bien
souvent une réalité mais l'ambition de
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un monde sans caisse du tout
amazon a déjà lancé ce type de
supermarché le client se connecte bien
une application tous les articles qu'il
prend ce scanner automatiquement
il peut repartir avec ses achats dans
son sac ou même dans sa poche
la note lui sera envoyé sur son
smartphone l'intérêt de ce supermarché
du futur le gain de temps
les machines intelligentes sont un
espoir immense pour la santé de demain
et c'est sans doute dans le diagnostic
du cancer que les progrès sont le plus
impressionnant pendant magazine en un
nombre massif de données des machines
peuvent détecter un mélanome à partir
d'une simple photo ou encore un cancer
du sein à partir d'une mammographie
aujourd'hui les programmes se limite à
aider les médecins dans des tâches bien
précises mais demain les dépistage de
cancer pourront être entièrement confiée
à des machines on est on est à un moment
charnière en matière d'innovation
technologique comparables à des grandes
révolutions industrielles
oui bah il ya la révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle
effectivement qui permet d'automatiser
des tâches compenser in automatisable
comme la conduite de voitures ou les
consultations médicales ou et donc c'est
vrai que mal mais chaque grande
révolution industrielle ça a été une
automatisation de tâches l'a déjà la
machine à vapeur c'était le mouvement du
ludisme et on avait peur à chaque fois
que ça crée du chômage de masse parce
qu'on n'avait pas là que les machines
remplacent les hommes et que du coup il
met les homos chômé vous reconnaissez
qu'il ya quand même des métiers qui vont
disparaître
oui mais on attend des fêtes
substitution à lorient et c'est vrai
qu'ils allaient nous faisons mais il ya
aussi de nouvelles d'eux il ya de
nouvelles activités qui apparaissent et
c'est tout c'est ça il ya des
discussions créatrice il ya des vieux
métiers qui vont disparaître ya de
nouveaux métiers qui apparaissent
médiatrice de nouveaux emplois que dans
pad est très bien c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est j'ai fait une étude on
y est mentionné dans le livre avec dumb
& co auteur nous avons tous les trois
plus un quatrième coauteur fait une
étude qui montre que les firmes qui
automatisent plus en france eh bien elle
crée plus d'emplois pourquoi parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle la substitution de du
des machines se substitue aux hommes
mais ces machines qui automatisent en
fait elles deviennent beaucoup plus
productive et donc compétitive et donc
elle augmente énormément leur part de
marché donc leurs commandes et du coup
elles embauchent oui parce que lesquels
de productivité l'emportent sur l'effet
de substitution et c'est ça qui explique
historiquement que ni la révolution de
la machine à vapeur ni la révolution de
l'électricité n'est conduit au chômage
de masse que d'aucuns avaient prédit
donc les emplois qui vont disparaître
parce que c'est toute la question c'est
la transition voilà comment on fait pour
cela alors donc c'est évident que c'est
vrai que l'addiction qui a écrit ça veut
dire que au lieu d'avoir toutes là même
toute sa vie le même emploi dans le même
secteur on va être amené à changer
d'emploi être secteur la caténaire parce
qu'elle nous a tous marqués cette
caissière vous essentiel pendant la
crise ce n était
on a déjà des supermarchés automatisé
sans caissière avec des roues il vaut
elle va elle va faire quoi une
reconversion vous pensez que on a le
modèle social et écologiste et pour
qu'elle puisse se reconvertir et pour
l'apa on l'a pas complètement les danois
l'ont trouvé ça s'appelle la
flexisécurité et qu'est ce que c'est que
la flexisécurité ça veut dire que vous
donner des garanties de revenus à
quelqu'un qui perd son emploi et des
garanties de formation pour les aider à
rebondir sur de nouveaux emplois et s
qui est ça ça marche si bien la
flexisécurité au danemark il ya eu une
étude par notre collègue alexandra
roulet qui montrent que au danemark
quand on perd son emploi sa aucune
incidence sur la santé
parce que le système était tellement
perfectionner et donc il faudrait qu'on
ait la même retrouve très rapidement un
emploi le leader du chômage on
recommande dans les livres à la fois la
flexisécurité est pour et pour empêcher
les trappes de pauvreté on recommande
l'impôt négatif c'est à dire qu en
dessous d'un certain niveau de revenus
absolument vous devez recevoir un chèque
automatique pensé comme un rsa
automatique
alors ya toute une série d'aidés d'idées
reçues que vous balayer aussi votre
livre notamment sur la question
écologique et le réchauffement
climatique vous dit non
la décroissance et fall ne permet pas de
lutter c'est pas la solution c'est pas
la solution
c'est à dire que doit y est c'est très
intéressant parce que le coc vide est
une expérience naturelle quelque part en
fait on a vu qu'entre mars avril mai le
pub a baissé à peu près de 30% les
émissions de co2 d'à peine 8 pour cent
donc on voit bien que la décroissance
n'est pas la solution
la solution c'est l'innovation verte qui
est d'aller vers oui c'est l'innovation
verte c'est-à-dire aller vers des
technologies plus vertes oil donc toute
cette innovation voulait lui qu'il faut
pas surtout pas la freiner vous ne
faites pas la freinent l'accès les
robots est une folie alors par exemple
taxer les robots est une folie parce que
on sait que les firmes qui robotisés et
automatisés créé plus d'emplois qu'elle
n'en détruisent maintenant ce qui va
pénaliser les firmes qui osent qui
licencient à tour de bras ou qui ont un
recours excessif aux cdd c'est ce qu'on
appelle le malus ça je suis tout à fait
pour mais taxer directement les robots
c'est aller contre les firmes qui
augmentent leur productivité leur
combativité en automatisant leur tâche
mais l'innovation elle vous permet aussi
donc l'innovation verte c'est la
solution c'est ce qui nous permettra
d'avoir une croissance durable de notre
niveau de vie tout en luttant contre le
réchauffement climatique et en tenant
compte des ressources et le moteur de la
croissance
rae
l'innovation vous l'expliquez vous le
démontrez parfaitement dans ce livre
dernière petite question très rapidement
vous parliez de la réindustrialisation
décélère on est en train de changer de
modèle économique
le libéralisme tel qu'on l'a mis en
oeuvre pendant la guerre froide c'est
fini c'est la régulation qui va primer
alors pas la guerre froide à dire que la
guerre froide la guerre froide est une
période industrielle puisque la guerre
froide et américain avait créé les
fameuses darpa les dix faces advanced
research project agency parce qu'ils
étaient en haïti
exactement donc c'était une politique à
date ans politi bird attend ce politique
industrielle mais c'est vrai que les
années thatcher reagan s'est détournée
de dire ces années là on laisse tout
filet et on aimerait et là à mon avis il
ya une prise de conscience que c'est
fini on voit les allemands fait ce qu'il
fallait faire les allemands mais c'est
intéressant parce que les allemands ils
ont conservé la maîtrise des chaînes de
valeur pas en faisant des guerres
commerciales comme 30 mai en hymne en
investissant dans l'innovation et dans
l'est dans la maîtrise des chaînes de
valeur et c'est passionnant le pouvoir
de la destruction créatrice c'est un peu
le monde d'après l'épidémie qui pourrait
devenir au fond une source du monde on
peut sortir ducobu par l'innovation
on peut relancer l'ascenseur social par
l'innovation et on peut lutter
efficacement contre le réchauffement
climatique sans être condamné à l'ailé
croissance grâce à l'innovation avec
c'est un message d'optimisme avec céline
antonin simon d'une aile c'est aux
éditions odile jacob vous restez avec
nous philippe aghion ça c'est l'heure de
la chronique de thomas des prêts il nous
raconte chaque soir sa journée à
l'assemblée et figurez vous que ce soit
jean luc mélenchon au coeur de
polémiques depuis l'assassinât
effroyable de samuel patty a décidé bien
de regarder ailleurs de regarder vers
2022 le leader de la france insoumise
qui propose d'en finir avec les 500
parrainages d'élus nécessaires pour se
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
c'est bien saint thomas
oui exactement myriam ce matin jean luc
mélenchon a convié les journalistes pour
une grande conférence de presse alors on
s'attendait à ce qu'il nous parle de la
crise sanitaire ou encore de la lutte
contre l'islam radical
mais pas du tout le leader de la france
insoumise a voulu s'exprimer sur
l'élection présidentielle je vous
raconte tout ça
[Musique]
alors au programme ce matin jean luc
mélenchon était venu avec une
proposition choc une réforme du mode de
désignation des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
à côté des charges en signatures d'élus
qui sont aujourd'hui nécessaires pour
obtenir l'investiture la possibilité de
participer à l'élection présidentielle
une autre voie d'accès c'est à dire
supprimons pas celle qui existe déjà une
autre voie d'accès existe qui serait la
collecte de 150 mille signatures de
citoyennes et de citoyens
alors la proposition de jean luc
mélenchon elle est ici six pages un
article unique pour permettre à 150
mille citoyens de désigner leur candidat
à l'élection présidentielle concrètement
ces citoyens devraient être répartis
dans au moins 30 départements en france
et ce serait le conseil constitutionnel
qui devrait recevoir leurs parrainages
alors cette proposition elle n'est pas
vraiment nouvelle lionel jospin l'ancien
premier ministre avait fait cette
proposition dans un rapport en 2012 elle
n'avait pas été retenue
mais qu'en pensent les députés
aujourd'hui on est allé leur poser la
question si ça permet de développer une
approche citoyenne une approche
citoyenne des candidatures à la
présidence de la république pourquoi pas
vous savez les élus locaux y représente
ses citoyens ils ont été élus donc moi
je suis pour qu'on maintienne ce seuil
des 500 signatures ça nous évitera
d'ailleurs quelques candidatures
farfelues élection présidentielle c'est
une proposition qui se réfléchissent et
c'est pas une nouvelle proposition
c'est oui ça se réfléchit je sais pas
pourquoi ça vient maintenant parce que
je suis j'espère que c'est parce qu'il a
peur de pas avoir ses 500 signatures si
je peux me permettre d'être taquin c'est
possible que le mélenchon 1 qui a failli
casser la baraque de 2017 ne soit pas le
mélenchon 2 de 2022
vous avez été candidat à la
présidentielle ils sont durs à avoir les
500 parrainages
oui c'est pas facile surtout que les
grands partis verrouille à mort mais bon
j'ai quand même eu donc ça prouve qu'on
peut les avoir votre avis pourquoi ils
font cette proposition là jean luc
mélenchon dans le tempo c'est un peu
curieux dans le tempo actuelle voilà je
ferai pas d'autres commentaires mais je
trouve c'est vraiment pas la priorité me
semble peut-être parce qu'il souhaite
faire diversion sur des sujets autres
sur lequel il n'est pas paru en très
grande forme une très grande force
je le laisse avec ces propositions dois
je dirais aux surprenantes et je me
concentre sur l'essentiel aujourd'hui
est comme à son habitude désormais la
france insoumise et dans laxe trad
extravadanses et compris avec les textes
fondateurs de nos institutions
on aurait envie de dire jusqu'où iront
ils mais je préfère pas le savoir voilà
mariam et on a demandé à jean luc
mélenchon s'il était candidat à cette
élection présidentielle de 2022 mais il
nous a pas vraiment répondu merci thomas
comment tenir comment tenir dans ce
tourbillon de mauvaises nouvelles
le moral des français est il à son plus
bas et que nous dit cet indicateur sur
notre avenir parce que c'est le temps du
décryptage tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir frédéric dabi soir merci d'être
avec nous j'espère que vous êtes en
pleine forme malgré ce contexte
difficile vous êtes le directeur général
adjoint de l'ifop et bienvenue à vous
viviane kovess masféty bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes psychiatre et
épidémiologiste alors les français on le
dit on le répète sont abreuvés de
mauvaises nouvelles il sort d'une
semaine extrêmement éprouvante puisqu'il
ya eu cet attentat effroyable de samuel
pâtit comment garder le moral dans cette
période de deuxième vague du coc vide et
bien l'humour l'humour comme antidote
c'est un reportage de nathalie gloire
voiture pas le moral voilà c'est tout
mais on met au oui avec c'est tout on a
l'impression qu'on essaie de nous
anéantir complètement les français sont
loin d'avoir le moral
pareil pour le gérant de ce restaurant
ouvert depuis moins d'un an
c'est épuisant de repartir à zéro on a
divisé le chiffre d'affaires par quatre
en une semaine c'est peu on attendait on
attendait tandis que les lignes avec
impatience dans ce contexte plus que
morose certains ont décidé de ne pas se
laisser abattre
dans ce restaurant au lieu du stand-up
on propose des spectacles d'humoristes
en plein après-midi et la fréquentation
est au rendez vous on a quand même pas
mal de monde qui viennent mois de plus
en plus les gens ont envie de rire je
pense puisque
c'est pas la meilleure des périodes on
vit actuellement autre chose de se vider
un peu la tête par rapport à ce qui se
passe ça permet de déconnecter pendant
un instant au moins pendant une heure
fois et la crise sanitaire est une
source inépuisable de sketches on a
rarement eu autant de matière dans les
infos dans ce qui se passe partout dans
le monde
c'est un peu difficile de parler de son
jeu juste de son ex avec ce qui se passe
en ce moment en quoi les gens ils ont
forcément envie d'entendre notre avis
sur ce qui se passe pour que à la place
des infos un peu bas dans ce qu'on
entend tous les mois et au moins un mec
là un truc à dire rigaud un truc rigolo
à dire sur tous ces trucs pas dans quoi
voilà ce pas toujours le quart des fonds
en vidant mais plein de fois ça se passe
super bien
et aujourd'hui pas de vide
des rires même masqués sont là mais
c'est vrai que c'est une façon de me
changer les idées de dos et de rigoler
on va moins dans les bars on va plus au
cinéma onf est quasi plus d'activité
donc là c'était un peu l'occasion de
faire quelque chose qui changeait de ce
qu'on fait depuis six mois une bonne
chose les spectacles comme ça oui c'est
le show que ça redonne l'europe de
morale mais ça permet voilà une activité
en fin de journée qu'on pourra pas faire
le soir donc sa route
ça motive france tout le monde c'est une
bonne chose de rire aussi de la
situation
la crise sanitaire et du coup vite donc
va pas sûr par contre que des prochaines
mesures fait rire les français frédéric
dabi il veut commencer avec le sondeur
que vous êtes voulait tester les
français sur cet indicateur du moral
depuis des années qu'est ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui que vous distille le
moral c'est pas quelque chose de binergy
moral j'ai pas le mona j'ai pas le moral
c'est toute une série de choses c'est
vrai qu'on est dans une période de
jamais vu
déjà faut pas oublier que le confinement
a été un événement hors norme inédit est
inouï qui a montré la résilience des
français qui nie n'étaient pas préparés
qu'ils ne s'y attendaient pas encore
quelques jours avant il ne parlait pas
de confinement
et puis le confinement a été acceptée
parce qu'il y avait une lumière au bout
du tunnel
il y avait une capacité à se projeter on
était dans une logique si je puis dire
août 1944
c'est à dire déconfinement le mois de
juin et les vacances qui arrivent là on
est sur quelque chose de complètement
différent
le pays vous le disiez encaissent un
triple choc sanitaire économique
n'oublions pas que l'inquiétude et la
baisse de moral économique est plus
forte la crise économique inquiète plus
est ce que la crise sanitaire puis le
mois d'avril un indicateur consul dupuy
mois de janvier et puis il ya eu le choc
terroriste qui a quand même je dirais
sidéré une partie du pays et qui a
déchiré on a vu comment d'ailleurs aller
les choses
nous on a une question historique
compose depuis une trentaine d'années
c'est une l'indicateur de morale pour
soi et ses enfants dans la dans l'avenir
et c'est un indicateur qui est compliqué
parce que il induit une capacité à se
projeter ce qui est très compliqué
là-bas et période que l'on vit avant les
annonces trion lieu demain c'est la
difficulté des français quasiment jamais
vu voudra peut-être un contre-exemple à
se projeter à
même très très court terme c'est ça qui
à mon avis sape le moral avec des
catégories qui sont particulièrement
touchés je pense sur le plan économique
au 25 29 ans la génération de
l'insertion qui ne peut plus sincères et
et c'est cette génération là analyse il
ya quelques semaines dans un sondage
europe 1 la tribune qui est le souffre
plus le plus de la crise y compris
psychologiquement et également ces deux
extrêmes du spectre générationnel les
personnes les plus âgées vivent très mal
c'est pas la question on dit souvent que
les français sont les champions du
pessimisme c'est pas nouveau
là on observe c'est pire qu'avant on
observe vraiment une différence pas
complètement d'une part c'est pas
complètement vrai c'est un pessimiste je
le dirai de projection c'est à dire et
l'inquiétude l'insa des enfants qui est
vraiment au coeur du pessimisme français
d'où le surinvestissement sur les sur
l'école et la situation de l'école et je
mets de côté ce qui s'est passé de 16
octobre inquiète très fortement les
français et puis de l'autre côté il y a
ce sentiment de pas voir le bout du
tunnel et là on a vraiment si demain le
confinement est annoncée c'est un point
de différence majeure entre ce qui s'est
passé le 16 mars et ce qui se passerait
en fin de semaine la fed en quête encore
mais si c'était annoncé donc je mets
beaucoup de conditionnel il ne le
comprendraient pas les français
je serai très difficile à dirais pas ça
ce serait pas la même logique que le
mois de mars au mois de mars était le
gouvernement nous tromper nous ment
notamment ceux des masques là c'est
plutôt la critique qui n'a pas préparé à
c'est la deuxième vague très bien
d'hygiène comes masféty vous êtes
épidémiologistes et vous êtes c4 vous
récoltez des données à partir de
l'hôpital des données en psychiatrie
qu'est ce qu'on observe alors je ne
récolte pas des données à partir de
l'hôpital les données sont récoltées à
partir de l'hôpital mais actuellement
elles sont pas disponibles c'est-à-dire
pour pouvoir dire quelque chose il
faudrait comparer l'année 2020 avait
trop tôt pour lui 2019 donc on a bien
2010 9 mai 2019 le coc vide est arrivé
assez tard et on a vu beaucoup de
concéquence psychiatrique 1 sur le
terrain du coc vide et de l'anxiété des
dépressions
comme vous l'avez dit je suis une
épidémiologie ça veut dire il faut les
chiffres pour pouvoir le dire ce qu'on a
vu c'est donc santé publique a fait une
enquête en utilisant un indicateur
d'anxiété de dépression mais qui n'est
pas un indicateur diagnostic on parlait
tout à l'heure du moral le moral ça
existe
temps n'est ce pas une maladie mentale
non ça c'est moi je suis psychiatre je
vous parle des maladies mentales dont
quand on dit que les gens n'ont pas le
moral ils sont tristes ça je suis né il
ya des signes les anxiolytiques les
psychodrames faut voir justement il ya
une très bonne étude qui a été publiée
qui suis un petit peu
pendant le confinement et à la suite du
confinement les différents types
d'anxiolytiques et de psychotropes d'une
façon générale l'utilisation des
antidépresseurs à diminuer celle des
antipsychotiques est resté à peu près
stable
quant aux anxiolytiques y sont beaucoup
pour augmenter au début et ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'ensuite ils
ont diminué et ils sont revenus à un
niveau à peu près normal et c'est à peu
près la même chose pour les ans pour le
moment l'épidémiologiste que vous êtes
nous dit l'incertitude
frédéric dabi par les incertitudes qui
au fond on caractérise cette crise n'a
pas d'effet enfin mesurable c'est trop
tôt pour le dire
sur au fond notre notre état notre état
psychique ou simplement notre angoisse
par rapport à l'avenir l'angoissent
c'est pas une maladie mentale
je veux dire des bandes est dans une
situation comme la nôtre en ce moment et
d'être anxieux voir de mal dormir ce
sont des symptômes
c'est une réaction l'être humain est un
être en réaction donc que les gens et
des réactions qu'ils en parlent entre
eux c'est un peu le on peut le constater
mais ce n'est pas de la psychiatrie m'en
allais pas de la psychiatrie c'est sûr
j'espère que ça fait pas le 2 à l'aller
mais on peut s'en réjouir ou peut tous
être angoissé 110 km je peux me voilà ce
que vous faites référence pourquoi
l'ascenseur social qui s'est cassé c'est
des rangs franciliens grand problème
avant on avait l'espoir que venant de
même de milieux modestes on pouvait
arriver en par le travail et l'ascenseur
social s'est cassé vous savez comme vous
le savez les indicateurs de blizzard on
sait que les tests pisa sont détériorées
et la dépendance au milieu social à
augmenter des tests pisa revoilà de la
performance au pisa ya le prochain
mobilité seule la question c'est comment
je relance l'ascenseur social est en
fait l'outil fiscal n'est pas le seul
outil
en fait les bons outils c'est les bons
emplois c'est à dire d'avoir des emplois
qui promeuvent qui permettent la
promotion et est en fête et firme
innovante elle crée de ses emplois ces
dernières permettent
l'être davantage donc en poussant
l'innovation vous poussez la création de
bons emplois
donc je crois qu'il faut vraiment aller
vers ces autres leviers ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut négliger le levier fiscal
mais il faut lui ajouter le levier de la
formation on a amélioré la formation
professionnelle avec les lois récentes
et le levier des bons emplois je crois
que c'est très important il faut
résoudre le problème la mobilité y en a
le temps où c'est tout à fait juste mais
en même temps les économistes regarde
ces indicateurs qui se sont devenus des
objets technologie rentrée en général
ils disent espagne parions toute la
gauche la crise de la gauche prg est
malheureusement c'est qu'ils pensent que
c'est en rétablissant lisf qu'il veut
relancer avec des social c'est
totalement faux parce que c'est une idée
fausse mais ça va sinon pas la solution
alors on va revenir à notre sujet
éthique sur le sur le moral
on ne peut pas encore dire sur une
évolution si vraiment il ya un marqueur
là c'est pire qu'avant pas déjà ce qu'on
a mesurée au mois de septembre quand il
n'y avait pas encore cette crainte d'une
deuxième vague c'était un indicateur
plutôt bon parce que les français
avaient mis à distance la maladie après
l'été qui s'était bien passé ils
pensaient que c'était fini donc on a eu
des chiffres plutôt bons alors que
traditionnellement le mois de septembre
est le mois de la rentrée c'est la mode
l'émoi de la crispation sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le mois pour voir y ait
des impôts en 2013 du ras-le-bol
fiscales et des du choc fiscal eu aucun
effet sur l'a8 et social c'est
effectivement et c'est vrai que là il ya
les chocs dont j'ai parlé il faut pas
négliger l'effet du choc du 16 octobre
faut pas négliger cet effet là il ya
cette dimension sanitaire qui est
particulièrement prégnante il sentiment
qu'il ya un lien entre sanitaires etc
impact économique et c'est vrai que le
pessimisme dont vous parliez en plus une
question depuis une vingtaine d'années
sur pensez vous que vous que vos enfants
vivront mieux que vous quand ils ont
votre âge et la charte il ya à peine 20
% des gens qui disent qu'ils vont mieux
et quasiment deux tiers ont moins bien
c'est là que se niche mais si c'est ce
que on parle de l'epargne qui
s'accumulaient ce qu est le feu choc
d'attentats terroristes 16 octobre le
moral en berne est ce qu on a déjà des
indicateurs sur sur la consommation sur
la capacité au fond de continuer sa vie
comme avant
je ne suis pas économiste mais on sait
bien que la consommation est l'un des
rares levier qui marche bien en france
mais quand je regardais capacité
d'épargné à travers des enquêtes donc du
déclaratif
il ya deux segments générationnel ou la
capacité des pagnes s'est effondré les
fameux 25 34 ans cette génération de
l'assertion et les 50 64 ans qui est la
génération la plus fragilisée qui entre
parenthèses votre le plus
tendanciellement pour le rassemblement
national et sur une enquête ifop il ya
quelques années on a vu en dix ans une
capacité des pannes qui s'étaient
effondrées de 19 points nous l'important
de chèque vert de chèques de
consommateurs de mon impôt négatif
s'élèverait mais je voudrais qu'on
revienne à vous comment se fait il est
jeune c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020 ses
statuts la nature matheron je vous
connaissez cette citation je ne
permettrai à personne de dire que 20 ans
et l'âge le plus heureux de la vie des
djeun ça a toujours été dit vous ne
voyez pas un tournant aujourd'hui avec
une chute à trouver un travail
alors il ya le problème des difficultés
économiques et des difficultés
d'insertion mais ça on en parlait bien
avant le coup vide ça vient pas
d'arriver alors d'amplifier les choses
voilà le coc vide c'est ce que je dis
souvent le covina un effet amplificateur
m'émerveille mais cette question de
l'insertion des jeunes elle et elle est
là avec les en différentes
elle est ancrée on la décrit depuis
plusieurs années c'est un problème de
société de même que les indicateurs
pizarro et de formation professionnelle
qui fonctionnait pas son professeur pour
conclure comme on garde le moral dans
cette période vous avez découvrir
l'humour mal vous avez commencé comme ça
je pense que l'humour c'est pas mal et
la résilience bâtir la résille arésiens
et surtout du côté des poids public un
cap et le sentiment qu'il ya un parler
vrai c'est ce que c'est ce qu'incarne et
un moment et dont philippe très bien il
faut montrer en tout cas vous montrer la
voie il faut montrer la voie de dire
voilà on peut ré industrialiser on peut
vraiment par l'innovation sortir du coc
vide faire une croissance verte créée
relancer l'ascenseur social montré la
voie mais on attend votre fougue et
votre optimisme
merci infiniment philippe aghion merci à
vous d'être seul sur le plateau des cp
très belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]